alors petits conseils pour bien savourer
cette vidéo je vous recommande d'aller
voir l'original avant sur ma chaîne
youtube
elle s'appelle chat en mission aller à
bon visionnage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était compliqué marins coopèrent pas
du tout là il n'a pas du tout envie de
jouer en fait donc des mots tournage
plutôt complexe avocats aux riches
empruntaient cette caméra qui récupère
et ça fait deux ans que j'ai pas sorti
et eu à l'honneur et le premier plan was
in dvc le premier plan du du making of
en train de lire la vidéo en fait il
aurait à vincent qui est vraiment au
bout les écritures de la vidéo c'est
fait mettez de livres et il fait le
grand écart
elle écrit vincent va nous dévoiler le
storyboard qu'on n'a encore jamais vus
nous de notre côté de la menace qui
veulent s
la [ __ ] tu vois ça c'est ta carrière
n'a explosion en détail
da je vais la faire exploser beaucoup
trop bien dessinés extrêmement mignon ça
va découvrir tout comme j'aime j'aime
bien dessiner dans mon lit tout ce que
j'ai dit alors les frérots on va faire
une sorte de photo du storyboard en
entier déroulé de a à z il est assez
long mais lorsque ça donne
pas durer ça c'est pour le making-of on
roule sur la plus belle avenue du monde
les champs elysées les mecs réactions
d'opposition actuellement comporter la
verna mobile 3g brolin je suis je peux
plus en fait nous sommes arrivés la mer
la mobylette intacte volant et après il
ya le bouton avec pour que ça décolle
pour tourner tous les plans de la vidéo
on avait besoin de petite patte de chat
en fait qu'on a coupé sur une peluche de
chat kiéthéga toi-même que merlin et
donc on utilise également le restant
cette peluche ou faire des plans sociaux
une peluche sans bras très très glauque
je vous fais un merlin qui vole ses
parties trucage
regarder la beauté des décors tout est
mignon près 5 au cimetière qui compte
rendu en fait j'ai sauté sur une vidéo
il ya aucun son à prendre en fait on est
en train d'installer le décor qui est
somptueusement fait de secret du trucage
du cassage de biscottes les gens savent
pas c'est que la biscotte elle est déjà
prêt si regardez moi l'agglo qui tue de
cette peluche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'effet spécial du grand écart
[Musique]
comment ils vont regarder la technique
pour que merlin ne fuit pas il va
sortire vestiaires on a juste barricadé
le tout avec de multiples matériaux en
fait professionnel aucun échappatoire
n'est possible pour l'animal ça serait
cool qu'en fait le planter en
arrière-plan de lui et genre tu
t'approches légèrement quand il est là
caméra
ouais ouais je suis un concept mobile
c'est une ouverture ouverture de la mère
amour il essaiera t il est ce pas avec
le coup ça on dirait qu'à une petite
ambiance un petit peu vintage et où nous
en sommes tous très culte
rené le tapis vert
eh oui la belle qui en sont totalement
prêts énormes attendre l'autorisation
finale pour vous mon rôle at il affirmé
ban au pardon tu touches pas de ta
position au silence ça tourne toujours
ça tombe toujours muet parce que ma
tante attend le fil à raison des
militaires égyptiens action
vous voilà super
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui ça
[Musique]
faire partir à vincent écrire des sas et
bourré tous les animaux et que tu as
besoin d'un petit coup de main on
ressent peut-être nous allons tenter de
faire démarrer un hélicoptère intra
muros
[Musique]
ja ambitions bientôt au cinéma attention
c'est une fin de tournage pour berlin on
va applaudir tout doucement pour pas
qu'ils aient peur
[Musique]
merci à toutes et à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo mais tu es un petit pouce en
l'air lâché un corps mais surtout pas
bonnes vacances en fait parce que là
c'est les vacances et bon courage à ceux
qui sont pas en vacances
parce qu'en fait on pense à tout le
monde 1 même les gens qui a acquis non
pense pas forcément au revoir